In this video, I'll show you step by
step how to program and add a new key to
a 2012 BMW 5 series F10. I used an
aftermarket key purchased from
AliExpress for only $20. The procedure
was completed using an Autofix IM1
interface together with the XP1 Pro IMO
tool. All the tools used are linked in
the video description. I started by
connecting the Autofix interface to the
vehicle's OBD port. Then I accessed the
IMO function, selected the BMW brand,
and used the automatic selection
feature. The car was correctly
identified via the VIN and I continued
with the IMO status scan function.
[Music]
After running the IMOSA scan, I
performed the quick DTC cleaning
function.
Heat.
[Music]
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
[Applause]
Once the process was completed, I made
sure there were no remaining errors in
any of the modules. This is a very
important step. Next, I use the key add
guided function. The procedure is well
documented and it's important to follow
all the steps in detail.
After completing step one, perform
pre-processing, you must follow the
manual instructions provided in step
two, generate a key.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat up here.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
At the end of the process, it's
essential that both step one and step
two display the final message, success.
Once that's confirmed, both keys will
function properly. If you have any
questions, feel free to leave a comment
below.